it was really bad and i was just like
i'm facing death this is what
dying is gonna feel like you know and
that moment god spoke again
are you ready like are you done are you
done with this
so you're sick you're not sure you're
gonna live
is it game over find out on this episode
of
led live
light exposing darkness welcome everyone
to another episode of
led live we're so glad that you could
join us today
and today we have another guest we have
a guest who was
you know we could say a little bit
involved in video games
uh or maybe a lot involved in video
games
today we have jonathan bell with us
today so jonathan welcome to the show
thank you guys for having me um it's uh
been exciting being here with you guys
um
you know um we're gonna talk all right
let's talk today i heard
not only in in video games were you a
champion at video games
i did win some tournaments wow so we're
gonna
so like when you say tournaments like
what are we talking like
those ea sports arena looking things
i was uh involved in like um
some of the local scenes here in
tennessee so we um we will go and
um it will be a good decent amount um of
people
we will join and we all compete against
each other so i'm always curious like do
do you get paid to do that uh yeah so
it's paid torment so it's um so if you
win
you will win money obviously but but do
you win anything did you get paid if you
don't win
no so if you don't win you just go for
you know so
it's a go for broke mentality yeah
basically yeah but do you have
sponsorships and stuff that like pay for
to give you the console yeah games so at
sometimes
it depends because you you basically are
like a marketing tool
so if they see that you are being very
successful and
you can pull a lot of uh you know people
to come watch you and you're performing
well
um then the sponsor starts to reel in
and
hey you know we'll accommodate you we'll
pay for this and that just to
so you can play our games you can play
our game wow okay yeah i watched a video
on the guy
ninja the blue hair guy yes and
dude he makes millions of dollars and
that doesn't include he's like the
underwear i wear
sponsored the every while he's playing
the game uber eats everything's free
yeah he doesn't play in his underwear
it's like a commercial oh probably i
mean
you know i mean hip-hop it's amazing
that
just to play video games you can get
free stuff
and get paid for it i mean that was a
dream of mine as a kid but i mean that's
the enticing thing from a lot of people
is just that you know
but it's got to be like any anything
right it's like there's
one percent of people that probably make
a living at it
and probably one percent of that one
percent makes a million and above right
i mean you think of all the people that
play video games and that's millions of
people but you
hear about the you know six guys that
are making millions on
youtube right yeah absolutely um
yeah uh i mean i wasn't obviously i
wasn't
as grand as these guys but i was very
much involved in what they call the
fgc which is the fighting game community
so um i was in there so like i saw some
things
what was your favorite game um
at street fighter 5 i think or street
fighter in general was
my favorite series out of all yeah now
you look really young to me so were you
were you around when street fighter
first started coming out
it was a popular game when i was a kid
yeah i was but you look a lot younger
than me so i don't know
well i'm 34. okay
so yeah um yeah i was when street
fighter uh first came out but i didn't
get into fighting games
off the back like it was i was
introduced to it
as i started picking up you know playing
video games
first so let's yeah let's back up and
back track i mean
how old did this start i mean i had to
been around
probably four five years old okay um uh
there's actually i actually have some
screens when i was uh playing
if you guys want to show us so you guys
can see some of these
so that's what you mean by being
introduced because a four-year-old can't
walk into a store and buy a
yeah absolutely so is that a ninja
turtle outfit yeah so this is me here
playing with my no no no this is
actually a sega
genesis if i'm not mistaken yeah correct
yeah okay i'm not even
sure your feet are touching the floor
yeah oh i think this was a controller
no no no no no so this is i don't know
if you guys ever heard the
stories or the means where um uh you
you know your little brother wants to
play oh so you don't want to disturb you
from playing so you give them a fake
controller yeah
he could think he's playing with you but
you're playing that's exactly what yeah
he's just about to act because there's
no wire connector
wow but still as a four-year-old
were you kind of internalizing you were
understanding what was going on you
actually thought that
you were playing in this game well yeah
and that's the thing about
um video game is kind of gives you like
this freedom of being in this imaginary
world
sort of um and a lot of people tend to
like escape to it i mean that's that's
the way i see it it's like it's you're
escaping to this world which is not what
you see around you so it's like a
different world it's an imaginary world
um and i compare it a lot with like
heaven i think that's what it is
probably deep inside people is it's like
this this
this need of being in a different place
you know but then you're presented with
video games
yeah okay so um yeah here in this
picture this is actually
uh when we lived in uh dominican
republic
um i didn't we couldn't afford video
games at this point in our lives
my mom decided she wanted to retire very
early so she bought a house in dominican
republic and we moved over there
and she took our uh me and my younger
brother with her and she left my
older brother and older sister in new
york in the apartment we had in new york
and at this time um what we got into was
um we had these things because the
computer we had no internet access
so we had this uh this thing called
emulators i don't know if you guys have
emulators so um so for those who don't
know
so what so what it is is basically it's
it emulates
a system so you it's a program that you
put in your computer
that will emulate or copy what a
video game system is so you can
basically virtually have a
a video game system in your computer
you're using it
like you're using a computer but it's
like sort of an app yeah
basically yeah yeah okay basically so
yeah so
um a friend of mine gave me and i
remember the floppy disk
maybe those young out there she didn't
know what that is
so um he gave me an emulator a super
nintendo
emulator and he gave me like about a
hundred games
and i put them in you know when i came
home that's the picture you saw earlier
and i went to town on this thing so i
was just
playing did you have a controller did
you have to do it on the keyboard
okay so i learned how to play it on
keyboard yeah
so we we did uh i did that for a while
um
but one thing that i wanted to note is
that it it's very interesting
games before had a different design than
they are now
i think for the most part um before
games had
a beginning and an end right so
when that game is done you put it down
and you go back unplug yourself from the
real you know from this virtual world
you go out you play you know i still
play sports i play basketball and all
these things
um but the way games are now they're
more designed to
keep people there now there's like you
know you have the online world so now
people can play online forever you know
go up two in the morning and get
connected and play against someone and
um so it it changes now now it's a more
like has a more pulling i mean video
games are addicting but now they're like
it's like stronger i say anyways more
in every design if you speak to any
software developer when it comes to like
games they're intentionally made that
way they
want you to keep playing this is why you
play those
mobile games and like it's so difficult
to reach a certain
level and then you got to you know pay
to play and you know and get some coins
to keep
you know it's like it's designed a way
that you have to spend here it's a
business
i can remember we were kind of breaking
down fortnite
um there was a couple guys that were
putting videos out there and just
talking about the psychology of fortnite
and why it worked
like like the fact that it was endless
they were like look you will never
finish this game
it's like literally open-ended to the
point where there's always a new skin
there's always somewhere
new to destroy or whatever and it's like
the little progress bar it never gets to
the full and
you know it's just uh they they use that
psychology to keep you engaged in the
game and i remember going like wow this
has probably got
tons of very smart people designing
these things because they know it
translates into money the more you spend
time with it
yeah like he was saying games used to be
really uh they were programmed a certain
way so you're like oh i know how to
beat this enemy i always jump on the
backside and hit them or whatever
you know you figure out how they work
but when you're fighting with
online people who are just as good as
you and they're catching on to how you
play and all that
the and and ai's gotten really good too
but
yeah you're talking about waking up
every day and there's a new expansion
pack a new world like it never
stops yeah or multiple missions or
multiple characters
you know you think about like the game
uh injustice like god's among us
you could choose like i don't even know
how many like 20 30 characters you know
and you could play the game from all
those different perspectives if you
wanted
and you think about all the the worlds
that are created now in games and like
just time it takes to explore that
to go from place to place i mean we
haven't even explored our own world
[Laughter]
yeah you know you bring up an
interesting point because i believe
that god created this world to be
endlessly explored
and so i'm sure the devil's looking at
that going hmm this is this is how this
system operates so if i create something
that just wastes your time and it's
endless
you know it's kind of tapping into what
god designed us to be like
because there there was a quote that i
read one time where um
i never forget it always comes to my
mind and it's about
christ being the creator of everything
right
we did not borrow anything from christ
christ created everything
right so everything is made by him
what the enemy does is pervert that's
right what god has created
that's what it is you know so if god has
something like love
he creates he perverts it lust right
so that's what he does and this is i
think video game is an expression of
that it's like you know
he's seen heaven right he's been there
he know what it's like
right so he's like you know what let me
introduce you guys a
perverted version of this and this you
know in this interactive world
you know no one gets hurt no one gets
hurt i mean it's it's a peaceful you
know
it's interesting or there's no rules
there's no rule you don't know what's
interesting
yeah so like sims yeah there's no two
more
no consequences your actions or if there
are rules hey
we got a game genie just pop it in right
oh yeah
[Laughter]
so yeah so these were
yeah turtles and times was one of the
games i played on that emulator
um one of the one that i spent a lot of
time was was uh chrono trigger
um i spent a lot of time that's again
speaking of this virtual world
um where you go in and you're exploring
and there's like multiple endings and
all this other stuff it's i think it's
about time
travel um and yeah so it just started
you know picking up i'm racking up i'm
playing all these games um
i was still into church by the way at
the time i was still my mom was a member
of the church and we was
still going to church and it just seemed
innocent
at the time it just seemed like well
it's okay it's a hobby
right that was my main line it's a hard
like any other hobby i mean i still go
outside play basketball i still
do you know i got good grades and stuff
it's it's fun i mean it's nothing
you know but it was not until
i remember uh we went to this uh
place in dominican republic called el
conde which is basically
uh it's like a colonial site like so all
these
houses and stuff look very old school
you know colonial-like and
um but they turn into like a strip mall
base so it's like an outdoor mall
right so um my mom used to take us there
every sunday
um so we walked by this place and it was
uh it was an arcade room
in there and for the first time in my
life i
seen a fighting game right and i
remember it was one of the titles
you probably saw before was that it was
called x-men versus street fighter
and i was just like blown away i was
like what is it like i remember x-men
when i was growing up
i remember those cartoons and i'm like
street fight i kind of have seen it
before and i'm like
in one world i was like wow it's all
just blown away
and you know and i was like mom please
you know give me some coins before i
could play and
whatever and we started playing and it i
got so hooked on this that we will go
home me and my brother and we will play
it
like ourselves like we will be in our
front yard
acting like we're the characters from
the game in our yard and like
who are you going to pick i'll tell you
like i'll pick for you and i'm like who
are you
okay sorry and we'll like be fake
fighting
that's how much of an impact that game
had on us video games don't affect you
though no no
no we're not absolutely not
right but yeah so that went on for a
while um
but in 2001
things changed so there was a tragic
death
in our family my older brother
had passed away um he was
put down by new york city police
officers
so my mom felt very guilty
about that she felt like because she had
left remember i told you guys she had
left them over there the older ones you
know to be in the apartment and
she felt like if she would have brought
her her babies with her like this would
have never happened so she felt very
guilty and
she was like i'm what you know i want to
go back
reunite the family again etc so
we came back to the u.s this is right
before 9 11.
and we have moved in there and
at my sister's house we got into my
sister's house well my mom said
my sister was living there with her
husband he had a playstation 2.
so now we're in like the playstation 2
era so
uh we went in there and we were not
allowed to play
that was the first thing you can't touch
it's a brand new system we can't
we can only see yeah we can't see them
play
and um the title that he had i remember
was
devil may cry one which should
isn't that an anime it's also an anime
they made an anime from the game but
okay
so the game was the game was from the
enemy then the anime came after yeah
uh which should make any christian run
away you know just a title
in video game right or violent anime i
mean that's
all the worlds are just hellish i mean
you're constantly around by demons
yeah he's the son i don't know because i
don't do these in death things like you
guys do but he's the son
of a demon who had a child with a human
and her name was mary and um about
religion
you know like i you know his hair is
white like wool and
i don't know it's just interesting you
know i never
thought about it that was just like
that's interesting you know
but yeah so um it was the only cry and i
used to
like you know play that i mean watch
them play and
um like you know when you like want
something but you can and you know
just but um time went on and
we i ended up um meeting the young
people
from church who were also into video
games right so these people
you know they're again they thought
nothing was wrong with it and
you know so we they're the one who
reintroduced me to the fighting game
genre so this is when i started picking
up on fighting game and they were
playing games like marvel's
capcom 2. and um street fighter 3
strike and super smash melee and
guilty gear so we were just picking up
on all these you know fighting games and
you know but at the time we were just
still mashing buttons i mean this is
what we just
like just go there and just you know
we'll call them they call them casual
players you know just casual players
just smashing blinds you don't know what
you're doing
um so we just you know continue playing
um but then it was until i saw a video
this kind of was like where the turning
point was i saw a video
um i don't know if you guys have it
there yeah i have it here
yeah so it's um it's called the the
daigo
moment so this is called the the
the most um impactful moment in fighting
game history
so this was in a tournament where a
player was
pretty much down and it was like a
comeback right so he did a comeback and
it was just oh everybody went crazy
and my mind was just like like
wow what is this like i never knew there
was like a technical
aspect to these fighting games like i
just thought that you just play and
match buttons and
jump around these people are playing
this professionally now
yeah somebody's like yeah wait hold on
like there's more
depth to this so so you're telling me
there's actually like
a a b a so there's no
numbers triangle no i mean
and it goes even much more deeply like
there's things like like
calculating frames so you know when you
press a button the frames for that
movement to come out
and then like they're plus and negatives
and it's just
it's a whole array of things that i
never knew but when i saw that i was
like oh wow so it's like there's more to
this than just
you know so i started so i started
practicing i started playing even more
now i'm practicing and trying to learn
and
and getting in depth so what started
happening is i started becoming better
than my friends
and i started beating them like
you know very um easily
now to the point that nobody wanted to
play with me so there's people like you
that made me not play video games
like i'd play for two seconds die and
then this person would play for two
hours and then i played for two seconds
you wanna see that clip uh yeah so okay
[Music]
do actually angry
so daigo is the the male character
okay he's fighting against justin warren
he's got a female character you can kind
of see the health bar
ken is almost dead right so
what he performs here it's uh
we got to see it's called a parry so
he's blocking
so the thing is here yeah see everybody
goes crazy
and he actually defeats the person in
tournament this was the you know
stage so what happened there he
if he would have missed time one of
those blocks would have been dead
[Applause]
that's pretty impressive something and
then immediately
react to it oh these they train how many
hours
and hours it's like a gym like you go to
the gym and they just practice
over and over and over i'm always
impressed with
the human body i mean we are capable of
so much more than i think we give
ourselves credit for
to be able to see something like that
split second like that and make those
decisions over and over and over again
and actually like you're going somewhere
with that i mean i hardly could tell
what was even going on yeah they've
deemed them the beast
after that like the eye coordination and
you know it was just wow you know so
that's what got me like
okay i want to do this you know and then
of course you see the cheering
yeah the people applauding i want this
i want the praises and all these things
so
um so i started getting into that of
course after i started getting a little
bit better nobody wanted to play with me
so
um so you have to go find people to play
with well not yet
because mama would not allow us to go
out you know so it still was uh
something came along that got us into it
i'll go into a little bit later but
um 2005 is when
things took another turn so it's
significant because of three things one
uh my son was born so i had a child
uh two i dropped out i flunked college i
dropped out i flunked college
because of a video game development by
three so who's in the third one in the
series so how what do you mean you flunk
because of the game
yes because i wouldn't not go to school
to play the game so you'd be up all
night long playing video playing the
game
and i yeah my dad teaches at a
university
and i hear this story over and over and
over again
i mean these kids are paying 20 grand to
go to school and they're literally
staying up all night long and can't even
function
in the morning i just
just i had to play i had to play you
know um
and then three was the first time i
entered
a fighting game tournament um which was
insignificant because uh
the grand prize was movie tickets
um but it was it was it felt good it was
like wow you know i won a tournament and
you know
it was the grand finals it was the last
match and it was pretty close
but you won i won yeah i won the first
tournament you entered the first one
right
i won so you know so that went on
um but again going back to what i was
saying
nobody wanted to play with me so i
really had no way to practice with
nothing so but entered now go easy on
you man come on
yeah i'll pick my worst character i'll
play with one eye
so enter next was the online era
so now the dawn of ps3s and that's xbox
360. i mean people who have pc
always played online but for game
consoles this was like revolutionary
like wow now you ever play online
with friends across the world and stuff
like that so
now i didn't need a nobody to play with
now i had
you know so this is when
the gaming problem ranked up to a
thousand
mm-hmm because now i just play
endlessly like it was just all the time
well because devil may cry isn't even
online no that
caused you to stay home and flunk out of
college yeah so now you're talking about
endless gaming endless players to play
with so so you've only got to college
and and your gaming likely as much as
possible
are you working yes and no
so i was jumping from job to job
um i remember i got fired
the first day i got hired the first day
yeah i went it was an accounting job
um so i had studied a little bit of
accounting um at a
at a program like i did an accounting
course and they was going to like hire
like basically like interns and
and that first day of my first interview
i i fell asleep
from being up late gaming on your first
day
you know so they hired me they were like
oh yeah you know i passed the interview
yeah you know everything's good then
they told me to wait in the way in the
waiting area
were going to bring the paperwork aside
and when they came back they founded me
you're like that
sound of sleep oh wow it's like
you gotta go buddy so when you're when
you're playing video games giving give
me a ballpark of hours like you're
putting what eight hours a day into this
thing um
probably more so um it was a job
to you for all intents purposes
sometimes i would play until
the sun was up the sun was enough we
weren't done playing and this is when
call of duty the call of duty series
came in
um before you move on walk me through
the
the mindset the mentality for someone
who can't even relate doesn't understand
how can you sit at a screen and play for
over eight hours
were you trying to progress to something
are you training like what is the
mentality what's keeping you there so
this is how i started so with call of
duty
right so we're calling we came on the
scene this is this is when i first got
the ps3 um actually my friend or
dominican friend they used to call it
cabecita
which is means little head and
the reason why they call it that and
it's kind of
gruesome if you think about it is that
when you shoot a player
in the head um call of duty does a
little symbol that looks like a little
head
like so it doesn't it does a different
sound than when you kill him any other
way
the head shot so this is where the name
came
cabecita which is hey let's go play
capexita which is
littlehead um so when this started
happening
um to answer your question it was uh my
friends
from around the neighborhood um they
were all talking about it i had no idea
what this was
and it was like oh yeah we all playing
galaxy then so i went and i bought the
game started playing with them
so it was more like a social gathering
online so they'll be in their house
they're you know it won't be their house
and we're all just playing online so it
was just like
it was like a big hangout mm-hmm you
know so that's kind of what drawed us
into playing and just like when you're
hanging out time goes by you don't even
realize you're like oh man it's four
o'clock in the morning
you know so it was it was like that so
that's what started you know
making us but then you're talking with
headsets yeah you're talking my headset
you're taking a smack or whatever
and you know um but
what happened is that after a while
i realized that it was like it wasn't
just because of my friends
okay there was something pulling me to
play more because there were times where
they'll be tired of sleep like yo bro i
got there
i'm done i'll see you tomorrow i'm tired
and they all disconnect
i will keep playing i would keep playing
and literally like i said until that sun
was not up where i would be like
whoa the sun is up i wouldn't turn it
off
wow wow so it was something there's not
i mean there is progression because they
do do things like i said these software
developers when they make these games
they
design them in a way to keep you playing
but with the online
seeing it you don't really need much
it's just it's online
so if i connect right now i'm playing
with someone right right
you know so the entering i guess would
call the entering wedge
into that gaming life that progressed to
something else was because of the
interaction
but how were how were your physical
interactions like with the family that
you were living with at the time
so very good question um
at that point my life my son was born
all right so um
i didn't really pay attention much to my
child
it's just something that i'm still
paying to like until this day
um i was
disconnected from everyone else you know
you know my mom would say like i'm
talking to you and you're like not even
here like
you know um and
at one point in our lives we moved in
together so me
she was not my wife yet she's my wife
now but my girlfriend and my son we all
moved into this house um
oh by the way i'm out of church at this
point mm-hmm um
churches i'm done with church yeah yeah
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i completely missed that but i
was you know i was completely in the
world it was just
i was done with church and um
so we were living together and it was a
disaster
our relationship was horrible it was
just we was fighting and
she kept begging me to get off the game
and again
no oh so let me ask you this what came
first trouble with the relationships
that you were having presently
um let me ask that again okay so let me
ask you this
what came first the issues with the um
interactions you're having with the
people you were living with
um that led you to the games or was it
the gaming
that started affecting the relationship
no i think it was gaming
gaming started affecting my relationship
with other people because
oh go ahead gabe i'm sorry i mean this
brings up a really kind of interesting
question how did you have time for a
relationship
you don't you don't i mean like how are
you gonna get a girlfriend because i'm
like i mean if you're gaming for like 10
hours a day you
kind of got a job sometimes like you
sleep
sometimes you know like when do you even
meet a girl
you know what i mean no because well my
my girlfriend i
met her before okay and then you know as
i started playing more and more and more
she was like whoa like this guy's like
not even here he doesn't pay me
attention it's like my son will
literally i literally will set my son
there
and i'll play and nothing nothing here
going on nothing
and this is common this is not just your
uh some kind of isolated case i see and
hear about this
a lot that gaming destroys relationships
and actually on the fortnight video they
said that
it was it was becoming one of the top
like five reasons for divorce it was
fortnite yeah
but yeah it's amazing how it kind of
takes over it shifts priorities in
people's lives
you met your girlfriend before you
started getting addicted or playing with
these games i'm sure you found joy you
saying you were playing sports you were
in church
then gaming came in and it seems like
all of that just became
yeah like like irrelevant irrelevant
right and now gaming is
it because i'm sure you didn't you
mentioned the church thing i'm sure you
didn't
come to a point in your life where it's
like i don't want to go to church
anymore
it was just a slow progression and
you're like oh wait i haven't been to
church
i'm too tired to go yeah i mean it was
like more like
like like um like
everything just started become boring
after a while like
you know because this this thing is
exciting you know you're playing and
society and then church is like
yeah you know and yeah the song and like
do you feel like there was a little bit
of conflict
of you know churches kind of over here
trying to tell you to like love your
enemies and turn the other cheek and do
good to those that hate you and
at home you're you're spending hours and
hours like you know i want to take this
guy out i want to hit the headshot so i
can hear the ping
you know yes and and interesting you
asked that because
something else was opening up you see
once you open the window to one thing
other things start to come in i mean
that's just how the enemy works it's not
just trying to
it's just more things starts to add on
it's like you open a floodgate
it's like you know just open the door
and so then after that
you know violence
started i noticed that my character was
more violent i was more like a
like a firecracker i expressed before
like uh
just you know any little thing i'm just
sparking yeah and
i'm sorry we passed over that you were
saying that there was
actually a different sound to when you
killed someone like with a headshot yeah
so how messed up is that
so you're trying to achieve that it's
like you know the rat trying to get the
the prize all the time like a leg shot
isn't enough
somewhere in the body isn't enough now i
need to get that head shot of course
it's going to change that's going to
mess with you psychologically
absolutely and i definitely didn't
notice um
my behavior was i was being more violent
um to the point where i was even
even abusing my my girlfriend and um
there's actually been videos of people
doing that right like where they're like
yeah just out of the frustration you're
in a frustrated state of mind
maybe someone comes in maybe it didn't
go so well or whatever
you're trying to like learn some new
moves or something and then all of a
sudden it's like you know hey can you
fold your laundry
yeah yeah if you're in the game and
somebody's trying to
i don't know if this affected you
outside while you're gaming or whatever
but
definitely like if you're in it you're
trying to win or whatever and somebody's
hey can you turn the game off you need
to yeah that's going to make you snap
i got a question too i used to watch a
lot of movies all the time in fact
when when my brother and i my parents
divorced early on and in my father's
house we watched no movies or anything
like that but when we visit my mom which
was a couple times out of the year
um it was like watch whatever we want so
we would just binge i mean watch
10 hours of of movies and stuff you feel
like
junk after that absolutely is that same
sort of thing happening in the video
game world it's like the more
time that you're spending like are you
walking away just feeling like
like you just watch tv and someone beats
you up all day long yeah i mean yeah
absolutely and and everything takes a
toll i mean physically
i started gaining weight i got to a
point where i
weighed up to 310 pounds you know in the
gaming grub
yeah well absolutely i was a grow pup
king
you know um but yeah so everything just
starts to take a toll i mean
physically mentally and recreationally
really yeah
everything just just spiritually yes
seriously i mean
i feel like that's the most important
one that goes i think that's the first
one that goes out once you start
engaging in these things so
um it definitely uh took a bad turn
and then other things started being
added
you know things of pornographic nature
um yeah because you can't just stay
there
you know it just started going downhill
from there it's that creeping compromise
that once you start
like loosening here it's like all of a
sudden
it's like i'm doing this over here so
what's the big deal over here so
it makes me want to ask a question and
you don't have to answer this
um but
as i watch the videos that you you sent
me
i would notice there was this character
that you always chose
and it was a female mika
and street fighter and it made me wonder
was she chosen because you wanted to
look at that character all the time
because typically like
she's like busting out of her clothing
hardly clothed at all and i was like i'm
wondering like
you know like is there something there
and it's like well i could be reading
into that or maybe you just get used to
the moves of that character so you stick
with it
maybe it's a combination of both yeah
i would say it could be a combination of
both
um i mean i did like the colors because
she was a she was a wrestler
that's that's her style his wrestling
moves and
she was a very cheap character what i
mean by that is uh
she was a character that if you didn't
know what you were doing she'll take you
out really quick
so that's what they call cheap
characters you know um
but there also is a relation because you
know
the enemy works very subtle you know and
there is a relation because
um i don't know if i could say this on
the show but one of the things i got
into
was um hentai
[Music]
pornography so i was gonna actually ask
that because it seems like
you know if you're focusing on
a digital female fictitious character
which
most women don't look like that right um
does that just kind of
wire the brain to that's what's
attractive you know
yes yes porn you know porn in itself
is destructive i mean you have people
who are like
secular people like they're not
religious and they will tell you yeah
i don't watch that that's i don't want
you know that destroys a mine
um i forgot what was this uh the
ex-football player
um terry crews terry crews
you know as far as i know i don't know
if he's a religious man or not i don't
think he is
but he had you know pornography
addiction and he said
when he was out he was like that thing
just destroys your mind right you know
so if these people are saying that and
they're
you know it's it's obvious there's
something there you know
and it's it's i think it just it blows
my mind how so many people go by and
think like it's
it's not it's just like watching another
movie right you know like
so yeah yeah i was gonna say it
for me i it was probably a combination
like that's one thing you can
see in video games for one a lot of
video games
glamorize evil it's always like dark and
demonic and stuff and then every female
character is going to be
sexualized um you know just the way they
look the things that they wear and
everything
and uh so me i always pick the most
demonic looking character or the chick
and that was that was why like with
killer instinct i picked orchid
i got really good with her the the
combos and all that
and and then with the second part there
was maya
which she was good too um but yeah i
would always pick either the most
demonic looking ones or the girls and
and yeah
i mean anime is the same way we've been
looking at anime and even the ones that
are for
kids they make the girls look sexual
socialized
yeah with dragon ball they got the
what's her name what's the girl's name
bulma showing her panties and lifting
her shirt and all that but
in like seven deadly sins which is a at
one point
recently was the fourth most watched
thing on netflix
and every single time a female character
is on frame
the camera's like panning from the
bottom up or she's in some
pose where she's bent over or something
it's like it's it's totally unnecessary
that somebody is drawing a person it's
not like you're talking to somebody and
they just happen to be sitting a certain
way
somebody is strategically drawing a
woman and it's purposeful
and just to add to that what you said
about um
you know these female characters um
there's one character in street fighter
called chun li who is known for being
very
you know i don't know what's the word
yes
you know and most
of the dlc so dlc is a downloadable
content like the extra content like so
they they release like extra costumes
and
you know they make them look even more
you know
chun li is the one the most downloaded
almost all the time the most downloaded
um
dlc uh you know costumes and so people
like not only they get these characters
they all like they also like dressing
them up in
a certain way so yeah so charlie is like
like almost like
like like nine to like one yeah it's not
crazy
it's just people just love getting that
carrot and just buying
all these sexy little you know dresses
for her and stuff like that so i think
that's a testament to how powerful god
created sex like he created
this desire for this
bonding that we have and you can just
see like the devil understands that
about human psychology
so well that he's like you know if i can
take that that we should be bonded
together in our normal relationships our
marriage or whatever like that and apply
that to this game
you're going to come back to that game
like a watering hole you know in this
product we took the children of israel
out you know and with balaam
yeah you know he's like well i got an
idea i know how to get him to fall
and those those in it i suppose don't
see how ridiculous it is because it's a
direct counter to god's ideal um god's
ideal was for you to be with your wife
but instead you're staring at a screen
or dressing up a character
that's not even tangible that you can't
enjoy physically when there's a human
that well i'm not gonna say is there to
be enjoyed but that part of the
relationship
is to enjoy her and i can only imagine
that's
the case in a lot of people's
relationships yeah there are people
there
waiting to be enjoyed but they prefer
staring at a screen they call them
waifus
the anime world that's what they call
i've heard that
you're a female animated
wow they use it a lot in the anime world
i'm surprised you didn't
hear that when you were doing an anime
research yeah yeah i found what a
weeb was in a furby so
you spend a lot of time doing this and
you know you mentioned the first
cinnamon you entered
you won that wasn't wasn't the last no
you entered numerous ones and you got
pretty good
like i mean you played a lot of
tournaments you racked up a lot of stats
and you got pretty good i'm not gonna
say you want them all
but you got pretty good and i'm assuming
you made a little bit of money here and
there
so um talk about that a little bit yeah
so
so what happened is um
so everything was destroyed so this is
this is i guess where the
um just to take you how how it you know
the um what's what i'm looking for the
progression how i went
so when i was
rock bottom right so this is at the
point of my life where i'm like
you know doing drugs um drinking
now i'm being with prostitutes
and you know it was just rock bottom
i received a phone call um
which was a a heartbreaking phone call
about something that had happened in the
past and um
i can't really go into it because i
swore in secrecy but um
it was really bad news just to say the
least right so this is it was really bad
news and
my will shattered i was just really
you know heartbroken um
i was crying a lot i was depressed and
as i mentioned to keith before
um this is the first time in my life
where i actually felt alone
so now even though i have people around
me i have my gains and whatever but i
just
i felt like empty like wow like like
what's even real anymore
for a time i was i couldn't sleep well
so i remember one day i i had looked
into
like music to help me fall asleep and
that's where i found
um a song called be still
be still my soul and
i remember i listened to it and um some
of the lyrics i felt like it was talking
to me like someone was talking to me
and i remember i heard that voice that
told me to pray
right and uh this is not the end i know
it sounds like i'm telling you like oh
is he wrapping up no no no no no this is
not your typical
conversion story so um
jesus told me to pray i remember this
and he told me to pray and
i don't know what i pray for but i just
was just like just wailing and you know
telling him
everything and you know but i felt peace
afterwards right um
so i started you know going back to
church and
christian walk even there were some
attempts the enemy did to stop me from
going to church like there was a one
point where i actually got stabbed
after church oh wow like he was doing
things like you're not going back
you know like i keep my i was still in
my church clothes when i got
you know this is these guys no no you're
back no no it was some gang members
and i got into this altercation and and
i
you know and they you know they jumped
me and wow
you know beat me up and stabbed me on
the floor um
but but you know god's grace you know
made it
and so yeah so i started going back to
church and this and and you know reading
my bible again and all this stuff and
listening to christian music so a lot of
things i started letting go like i was
like i was convicted of like like
worldly music like oh i can't be
listening to that and
you know certainly dies like i can't be
eating that and you know like i knew
like
you know god was bringing all these
convictions back and like i felt like
like a baby again you know studying and
rediscovering this world
you know but i couldn't let go of video
games
i kept that little one in my pocket you
know this little cherished little idol
just like it's okay i mean there's no
commandment that say thou shalt not play
your xbox right you know there's no
commandment that says
you know don't go on call of duty or
play you know so
i just kept that this is all right it's
all right
so what happened again is as i started
playing you know kept playing
that love and this for jesus and this
whole thing
started to crumble again
so this is now like now i'm going even
deeper because then i
what happened was i started i remembered
about the professional
world of fighting games and i was like
maybe i could do this for money you know
so you think like oh man i can just do
this you know
i'm good at these games maybe i just get
in and just started
so that's when now fast forward to the
point you brought up where
i started playing um professionally
professionally
do you have to pay to enter in or yeah
so you pay for the tournament fee
it's like yeah okay exactly yeah so it's
like you pay free to go in
um depending on the group of staff
people that enter the tournament
you win the pop money if you win the
grand finals you know second and third
place also get a percentage but
much less of course how many people are
you talking about um
no i mean depends it depends it could be
10 100 be a thousand 2 000 players in i
mean just all depends
you know how popular that tournament is
um
the one they do every year which is evil
which is the super bowl
a fighting game uh sometimes up to has
up to two hundred and fifty thousand
engines
wow so what's what's the purse on that
oh um i think i have seen
about two hundred thousand i think
yeah so it's uh if you want them right
there and you know they're probably not
entering unless
they think they can they can win
absolutely you know some people might go
for the experience
no it's an arena it's literally like um
it was like
like the suit it's like the super bowl a
fighting game i mean this
they rent this huge place down in las
vegas every year and
you know i didn't get to go to evo
you know it was it was my thing like i
was like oh man i wish i could go
i don't understand this world anymore i
really don't know
can you see these these these colosseum
000 people all staring at two people
playing a video game
and i'm just like and not including
those online watching as well
but those are not even the big one i
mean fighting game is still like
a niche a little bit like if you go into
like
the shooters like um counter-strike and
fortnight and all these these people is
million-dollar prices right like the
grandfather you win you get a million
dollars
and the mob i think one of the
tournaments i forgot which one was it
it's one of those role-playing games um
had more viewership than the super bowl
i think in 2019.
yeah i've seen that that's just this i
forgot what
if i can remember the name of the game
but um and i think they were also saying
ea sports
um they were talking about digital or
what do they call them they call them
digital sports right
or yeah um esports esports
it's called athletes which i think is
hilarious yeah but
these this is making more money than
like
a lot of these sports put together yeah
which is what
they they're betting on real hard i mean
the gaming industry is a multi
billion dollars and it's it's all age
ranges there's
there's these videos i've run across
that have millions of views and it's
kids like little kids playing roblox
and it's like i don't know why why
people like watching it but it's like
a dad and his son they're playing
together and they're oh no
they're like kind of narrating what
they're doing or whatever and i guess
that's the entertaining part is
hearing their expressions or their
reactions and stuff
so here's the world that we live in we
watch other people play video games
we watch other people watching movies
and we
somehow don't have time for anything
i don't know but we're paid to do it
though
who needs a job when you can get paid to
watch movies or play games right yeah
that's what i'm thinking like is it
possible to have a balance like if if i
were to say
my job is to play video games like
i'm preparing i'm practicing just like
someone would practice for
the olympics i'm practicing for this
super bowl event
to get a million dollars would my
lifestyle reflect that of someone who's
addicted to this game
well that's what they uh say that you
know
these people are professionals so you
have to differentiate
you're not an addict right you're not a
professional so don't
don't play that long don't you know they
still throw all those
you know disclaimers you know don't play
in front of the screen for too long and
but i mean who really is monitoring that
right you know it's just
money shouldn't be a justification yeah
yeah i i still think it's a very strange
thing because
if you look at like michael phelps right
i mean he
is the most decorated athlete we have on
this planet i mean for a long time he's
won more golds
than anybody anybody like added together
on teams he's won more gold that one guy
and i saw an interview with him where he
said all he wanted to do is play video
games and he was
absolutely miserable like like that
wasn't happiness to him
you know here he has all this money all
this stuff all this fame all this
fortune from that and it's like
he's just escaping in the video games
and that that wasn't didn't even make
him happy
well um it's pretty pretty crazy
and it is i mean you don't you think
you're
you feel the excitement and it's just
like with anything
you know anything that grabs that
addiction you feel like oh this is
this is but it's really not you have to
continue doing it over and over and over
i mean in itself it's prepared to be
addicting that's the way i look at these
things are just
made to make you an addict they're not
made for you to play it two hours and
no they're made to i mean i got people
grown folks who still
hooked on candy crush right they could
go for
days playing candy crush and they can't
let go and you know so
but yeah so um sorry we'll worry
so you got it pretty good you're in the
tournament yeah the tournaments the
tournament scene yes thank you
so yeah so i started entering
tournaments um
[Music]
i played in a few states i played in
ohio for a bit um
i actually competed against some of the
bigger like big names and fighting we
were still married and everything
no i wasn't married at the time still
still not yet oh
but you're still together in a
relationship yes even through all
everything yeah i mean there were
spots but yeah
um so so yeah so i'm starting entering
these tournaments i'm
playing against people like uh like rob
tv
which is a known you know fighting game
player um
online i fought um one of the world
champion
which was uh um i don't
this is his name i domination i i
nominate you
basically i beat them yeah i really like
that
i beat them in a quick match so
um so yeah so i started entering um
these tournaments so what my big break
in tournament was i went to a uh they
called thursday night throwdowns
that's when we had already moved to
tennessee and um
well first i started going to this local
scene and then from there
i got connections and stuff like that
and i went to this tournament called
thursday night throwdown and i won the
grand finals
and it was like a close match again this
usually ends up being like that it's a
close match and
you know everybody cheering oh you know
um
so that's what kind of like when i was
like okay like this is what i'm doing
now i'm doing this you know so i started
opening up
podcasts i had gaming podcasts um one
that was called nephew what up which i
did it with my nephew
co-hosting with my nephew and it's the
premises was that it was like me and my
nephew will get
on the phone and like gossip about video
games you know um
and that was going to ride we had um
i had some sponsored videos i don't know
did i did i send you those
no i had some sponsor videos for um
these companies that make like rubber
grips
for the controllers so they wanted me to
sponsor them and
i mean they want to sponsor me and so we
had that going on
um so yeah so now i'm like really
invested in this
you know but at the same time
um physically i was uh
not doing well so yeah so this is a
little local place where we uh we went
to
i said i'll go there they used to call
me the legend
[Music]
and that was the tournament yeah and
i'm trying to get to this part where you
said though you weren't doing so well
yeah so that doesn't look too well that
doesn't look too well
so uh
gaming this is what it is with game
especially fighting games
it's called it's basically
long nights short days so
you're basically almost up all night
playing right because you gotta get
the you know you gotta get good at it
you gotta practice you gotta do
streaming you gotta go on twitch every
gamer now especially fighting games you
know they have to go on twitch you have
to stream because that's what gets you
out there
um but why at night like all day
how twitch works is there's slots so you
guys mentioned ninja earlier right
ninja has a slot you don't want to
stream when
ninja streaming because who's going to
watch you right you get what i'm saying
so
what slots are available the late nights
wow if you're a newbie
the late nights sounds like broadcast tv
so that's how it works so it's like i
mean there isn't no set
you can stream whenever you want to but
if you want you know to grow
you got to pick and choose as you
progress does that time change
like okay tomorrow i'm bumping it up an
hour yeah i mean
it all depends because you know if if
i'm more popular than such and such
then you know my viewership i can you
know and then also depends on the game
like you know what games people want to
see so if i'm playing this game
and i'm more popular than this guy
playing the same game
who's going to get the viewership i am
now who's watching this stuff
who's up in the middle of the night just
watching other people play video games
other gamers
so did you watch other people i watch
other people as well all the time
yeah so if you're not playing you're
watching if i'm not playing i'm watching
then that's the thing because
in the game in the fighting game you're
always picking up on what's called
tech so this is what tech is basically
it's um it's the word
i'm not explaining but it's like
technology technical
well exploit that's the word is so it's
each game
has systems right when developers make
them have system that this is what you
can use is what you can use is
this how you play this how you use it
tech means exploiting those systems
outside of what the developer intended
it to do to get an advantage
on your opponent right so gamers
fighting
you know uh gamers are always trying to
find new tech
so sometimes people when they're
streaming late at night they discover
new tech
you see it you copy it now you add that
to your repertoire that's gonna
just seem like the devil is like that's
right here's the tech that god created
here's humanity
i'm gonna figure out how to break the
system that he made
so i can have an advantage over my
opponent yeah absolutely like
subliminal messaging and stuff like that
like i'm going to get on there i'm going
to exploit their psychology and exploit
they're like this and then i'm going to
figure out how to break that thing so i
can now have an advantage
that's exactly what it is i mean i mean
they're buying
in their nature so i mean you add that
to the bonus though
um so yeah so so yeah so
streaming i was doing podcasts and
i was gaining weight lots of weight like
i mentioned i was
310 pound at this point here um
eating late night eating all kinds of
things that i shouldn't be eating
um and again my spiritual life was
shut down this point i was just like not
even going to church
playing on the sabbath that's one thing
most tournaments
are on the sabbath yeah anyway so so i
mean
you know just like what do you do so
eventually you compromise if you're into
this you compromise you start playing
you know um
so i went to the hospital i thought i
was gonna die
that night um i remember i even um
i said farewell to my son i i
told him i said look son i don't think
i'll make it because i think i mean it
was really bad it was like
it was like a strange headache rapping
from like the back of my neck
my chest felt like i was going to have a
heart attack my chest was like up here
it was just
like i was like i don't i don't think
i'll make it this is it this is it
and um i went to the hospital
and while i was in there uh god spoke to
me
um he told me are you done
like are you done do you want to
play some more what i mean what do you
want to do you know and i think that's
god's way of letting us know like
sometimes he he just has to let you see
the way you're going mm-hmm you know
he's always protecting us god is always
there because
some people probably ask like where was
jesus didn't this guy had a conversion
earlier you know a few years before and
he was
you know praying to god and like where
what jesus was there the whole time
he never left you know but we keep like
like trying to jump out of his hand i
mean he says nothing can come out but we
keep trying to jump out of it
we keep trying to get out of it and he's
just okay
all right go ahead take a look go ahead
see where you're heading to
and i think this is where i was at in my
life so
um there's a way that seems right into a
man
at the end it ends in destruction
absolutely we were just reading a
comment earlier somebody was saying that
they didn't want to give up the things
that they
enjoyed because somebody was forcing
them to or something and we're like
that's the joy of god that's his love
that he gives us free will you want to
play the video games
i'm not going to stop you but i'm
telling you there's a better way
and i i want you to come this way or
whatever but
i'm not going to stop you from doing
what you want to do
um i mean he's that loving that he gives
us
what we want and we choose that path
even if it brings you to this and then
he's right there he's not saying uh
you already had your chance you walked
away you played you chose the video
games now he's right there
are you ready you're ready to give it up
i mean even if you would have
died in there he was still there are you
ready to
you know come to me you could you could
have you know come back to him at your
last dying breath he's always there man
waiting for his product was soon to
return
and that's the thing i mean and i was in
a really bad spot
in this time like you i swear when the
bible speaks of
when you don't clean the house right
you guys heard that when you don't clean
the house what happens no demons
seven more come in right that's exactly
what happened
so when the first time you know god came
to me and
you know he saw and i and we prayed and
and you know and i started
making changes i didn't clean the house
i left the little altar there in my
house because it's really what it is
it's like an altar it's just there
and you come and you give it your
worship i mean that's that's what it is
you know revelation speaks to us how we
worship man
yeah pay for that little costume you
guys don't know how many times i
sold the ps4 and bought it again and
sold it and bought it again and so
you know me trying to like no i'm going
to give it away and then buy it again
that's a classic sign of addiction you
know
exactly go dig it out of the trash throw
it away
same way so many times just okay just
one time just one time just you know
hook it up and wait a new game came out
so um wow yeah so the
um so what eventually broke that cycle
this experience right here
yes so what broke the cycle was when i
was faced with
death wow like here face to face you can
die
right now you know because that's that's
how i felt i literally felt like i was
going to like everything i mean my body
was so i was just
i don't know how to even explain
thoroughly just how i
felt you know like i just like i said
crazy headaches chest i thought was
gonna have a heart attack
i mean i was slurring words it was it
was really bad
it was really bad and i was just like
i'm facing death this is what dying is
going to feel like
you know and that moment
god spoke again are you ready like are
you done
are you done with this like how much
more do you have to see to know that
this is not
good for you i don't want you to go down
this path
you know so god answers right away
and right afterwards
um the doctors came with all the tests
and everything and
that was like seven hours later i think
so six or seven hours later
and it was like yeah you're fine
but yeah go home just follow over your
primary care doctor you're good
no heart attack no no nothing cancer or
something i mean
give me something no you're fine
i was like interesting which is unusual
because
hospitals are a business too i mean they
could find something wrong with it just
like a
mechanic i looked under there or
something yeah that
that's wow yeah so did you stay
in that path of saying i needed to make
a change
or was it like playing with your mind
you're walking out there going okay did
i make that up
okay i'm really i'm fine i'm gonna keep
going so i went home
i went home and i got on my knees and i
started praying
and this is literally how god answered
me
be nice to your wife
i'm here confessing my sins i'm here
telling god i'm so sorry i know you told
me to get away from these things and i
didn't want to listen
and i'm sorry for for you know doing all
these wrong things and all this sin in
my life and
be nice to my wife i was like well they
got to do anything
it made no sense to me i think this
thing's broken in here
[Music]
but as i started walking with god and
started studying reading the bible and
coming back again
i understood what he was saying
the destruction you was doing to your
life did not affect you only
it was affecting those around you that's
right my son
and my wife now we're married now sad
they were affecting them too and you
never realized
you thought it was just you you thought
it was just me i'm i'm gaming i'm doing
my thing and
you know i'm just out there i'm you know
i'm gonna make it in the world
like but those things are affecting
those around you that was
that was his answer he said be nice to
your wife
it's beautiful and i was like i
understand more so
after that um i gave my life to god for
real this time
and on october 2020 uh i was baptized
it's pretty awesome very recent
yeah so yeah it's hard to imagine you in
this state because it's like
from the second you walked in here you
just have this kind
sweet peaceful peaceful yeah yeah
peaceful is an
excellent word for it um you just seem
like like
you can see it in your eyes and it's not
like that you know
just tore up struggling oh no it wasn't
like that
it wasn't like that but it's uh by god's
grace
um he changes us and we don't even know
how i don't still think i am changed i
don't still think
you know my mind i'm still a worthless
sinner yeah you know but he's the one
that makes a change
you know so after
you've been baptized are you involved in
a local church
how has your life changed since then
so uh very interesting um
or good question i'm sorry keith uh it's
i am involved now in the church
okay and they made me uh director of the
missionary department um
you going to work my man which is good
because if you don't work whatever hands
that's
true that's right james tells us
he knows you need something to do yeah
exactly so um
so i'm out there i'm spreading the word
i've always got my little
pamphlets or something to give out and
um i do lift on the side
so nice you know i meet people and hey
here you go and sometimes i talk to them
like driving yeah let's not wait
no
[Music]
but yeah so um now i you know
you know i just meet people a lot like
you know while i'm driving and i'm
always
you know giving out something just
something to people give them something
to
you know and people you know drivers cab
drivers because i was a show for new
york city
um we are therapists
yeah people get in the back and they
just feel the need to just tell you
everything oh and i broke up with such
and such and
my bills and i got kicked out and you
know and it's a it's just i feel as
a wedge you know to open and you know
give the word of god to them
i hear a show coming on taxi cabinet
can we do a round show a reality show we
can follow you around
have you ever um have you ever
encountered any gamer since
i have a gamer who's very dear to me
okay it's um my nephew i'm going through
jason
yeah so i actually was the one who
introduced him into the gaming world
which
now i see again what god said what you
do don't affect you
it affects those around you how's that
relationship now
so it has changed a bit um
but he does respect um you know
my uh my decision i did have to
have a talk with him and to apologize
you know
for what i was doing and the way i was
leading him and i introduced him to this
world
um he listens to me a lot i mean he
looks at me like like father
figure and that's why he grew so
so close to me um but he does he
respects
what i do in fact i love what he tells
his girlfriend
uh when his girlfriend had asked him
he's like hey
what happened to your uncle yeah because
we just live in new york so he's
happening uncle i haven't seen him in a
while um
you know what's going on i don't hear
you talking about it because you always
used to talk about him
and he answered he says he's on to
better things
[Music]
as we're kind of wrapping this up i have
one question there might be
some people like that are immersed in
this gaming world
if you had one or two sentences or even
just a short amount of time what would
you say to those people that i mean like
are where you were what advice would you
give somebody that's literally
just checking out for 10 12 hours out of
the day i will say
this um the first thing is that
um i think i might be stealing some of
the quotes that i have heard you guys
said before but
um video game is art you know
it's uh it's a visual
representation of what the
you know the creator is is intending to
put out
right so it's uh it's uh
it's it's meant to affect i mean that's
what art is right you guys have said
this on the show before
art is meant to affect you and
we know through god's word
that things can only affect you in two
ways either
towards god yeah that's right go away
from god you know there's there's no
ground there's no middle ground
the devil likes to play that a lot he
likes to make you believe that
yeah you're neutral no that's not how it
works
it's either towards god or away from god
so
you know are these video games drawing
you closer to god
or are they not and if they're not then
you have to make a decision
you know so um i've been through it
i lived it for decades literally decades
you know um but i know that
if if you really want to give your life
to god
these things gotta go they gotta go they
can't you can't
um what's the word you can't have uh two
masters
two masters you can't be between you
know two votes so that's true
um i praise god that he he was patient
with me enough
right he didn't let me die on those two
almost
when i was stabbed and when i was in the
house he didn't let me die
um he saved me from that but he saved me
into his uh
his loving grace but there's there's
another group of people here
as well the support system of the gamer
yeah you know you were in the hospital
and i'm sure you had a worried mother
you had a worried wife a word son
what can the people around the gamer do
to help
um no one wants to see their loved one
get to the point of death before they'd
make a a change
so could you think back was there
anything that you needed to hear
is there anything that could have been
done to maybe help you along
your spiritual journey well the first
thing is i would say
and i guess this is more towards like i
guess church
you know people going or members or um
support your young people one of the
things i didn't mention in the story but
one of the things that happened with me
is that no one ever gave me a bible
study interesting
throughout my whole life going to church
no one ever gave me a bible study they
just assumed when i used to go to church
they assumed
that i was a member from another church
now visit because i just like i knew
things
yeah my mom had told me things and and i
would speak like
like if i'm a church member but no one
has ever given me a bible said no one
had taken the time to
hey you know which pie would have helped
more yeah
you know um and brought better
convictions into my life that these
things are not
good for you so i would say one
pay attention to your young people you
know don't think these things are
innocent
my mother i didn't went into the story
again but she made the mistake to buy me
a ps2
you know and her thing was it came from
a sentimental background because
she said the story she actually told me
a story in front of the store
i have to hear this now mom but right
before buying it she was like well when
i was young
um my parents i always wanted a doll and
my parents never got me
the doll and even though i did good i
had good grades and i did everything
good they never bought me the doll
you know so i don't want to repeat that
same story with you i know you've done
good so i want to
you know and it sounds good but you know
little did she know the evil that was
going to unleash
yeah you know afterwards so don't don't
take it for granted i don't think these
things are innocent
you know study i don't am i going to
call every video game evil
i can't make that call you know but
you know these things have
a tendency to be addicting and
it leads to other things what i'm
hearing you saying is like education is
important
not just in the video games field but
also spiritually when someone walks into
the church don't have any assumptions
treat everyone like the learners that we
all are
that's one thing i appreciate in college
is um
i had a friend who was a baptist
and he did not leave that question to
chance
like he knew i
would identify as a christian but he
made it a point to ask me like point
blank you know do you know jesus
is your savior and he was just like you
know when
went right to it and i think that was it
was really cool he didn't make an
assumption about it and so we should not
make that assumption with
other people what i think is also cool
too and what i'm hearing
is not to necessarily walk in the door
and be like
you shouldn't be playing video games and
i'm going to show you in the bible why
yeah
it's almost like like give an
understanding let the holy spirit work
with that person
you know i mean it's okay to engage and
talk about things because that's
relevant to them too but
maybe not coming just directly at that
angle but to just say you know like hey
man i want to have some bible studies
with you about
you know yeah a lot of other things well
jonathan
i really want to thank you for coming
and sharing your story your experience
that has been
a powerful testimony and and i think
just testimonies are powerful
in general um i i really
like how seeing how god worked in this
because it
god brought you to the point where he
said
basically are you over the games
or is it game over you know for your
life
and he was willing to let you make that
choice
one thing i hear coming out of this too
is the aspect of
how much time this uh
absorbed in your life you know it comes
in and just like
like a swarm and it just like it crowds
out all these other things that you no
longer have time for you don't have time
for relationships you don't have time
for
the circle of friends around you you
don't have time for
sometimes even a job you know all these
things got crowded out and that's one
thing that i like to talk about
a lot is the time aspect you know what
are we doing with our time
the book of ephesians says that we are
to redeem the time
so here we are on this planet time is
running out what are we doing with the
time that we have
and so i'd like to challenge you as an
audience member
you may have never been into video games
you may have never
had that kind of addiction there may be
other things in your life
what are you doing with your time on
this planet how are you treating the
people around you are you spending time
with them are you spending time with
your family your children
uh your friends do they know that you
care about them and how are you showing
that
so if you have if you find yourself in
that spot if you find yourself
addicted to something god can bring you
out of that just like he did in
jonathan's life
and so we just want to encourage you to
cry out to god
ask him to show himself to be real to
you and he definitely
will so thank you again for joining us
thank you again for joining us
and we will catch you next time on led
live amen
[Music]
i love anime i love it i mean
i can't watch enough of this the duelist
who they say can speak with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation
at a local school and concerned from
parents the death note is derived from a
japanese animated show
the girl told authorities she got the
idea from a cartoon network show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Music]
um
you